hello and welcome to this video playing
home boiled Calabar and this is not the
first game I played him quite a bit
[Music]
two games sync let's try the Catalan I
place the main line okay
I've tried a couple of lines there over
the years
I've forgotten most of it
in latex divorce
such a great move 94-94
you should G 296 I think is possible
they usually play night two before him
night to be four and then night bd5 is
double the standard approach
you
you
Oh Kim mm-hmm so he tries to prepare
see five
see five is a desirable move of course
but still a little bit puzzled why you
need Roxy aid when you probably can play
that but
night before 95 looks quite normal okay
now where do we go
maybe this is a square
but then
22 maybe you just place your five then
okay let's get good with me
most obvious anyway so now c5 d take c5
should be okay for me so he goes with
this and now yeah do we take I don't
know
I think Roxy one should be an okay
choice I don't really mind if he takes
on f4 this is usually not a problem
Oh
you
that looks like a good move
we're take on d5 you would probably take
with the bishop
and look at mine
- pong
you
stink
yeah I wanna I don't think I can stop
see five that does not seem to be
possible
see 590
there still be 55
yeah it's just like wise I think Queen
e8 was a good move
definitely
yeah now with her insight I probably
shouldn't even have played Bishop g5
No
yeah it makes some sense
you
not taking on g2 but instead covering at
it is a bit more active
I have a I don't really have anything
okay I can take an A for that is
something that I didn't even hope to get
now I have created at least a small
weakness down on his in his camp now
usually the C file is the more
interesting file to play play on
okay
interesting choice h5
I need to watch out for the time I have
time problems and no ninety five is a
position problem I shoot
we am sponsored his spots
of Queen a5
I had a stupid way a stupid way to Numis
to run anything running into that bloody
tactic
you
cannot even activate
much 16 seconds
you
it should be six as a strange move
somehow it seems to be good
you
I'm certainly lost in some way
I don't
don't see yet how exactly
Queen age 7 huh
I got night h3 okay
Wow okay that's funny
nice one why there was a stupid loss
because after a four I'm simply better
for nothing
yeah this is just this is noise and
losing is is really impossible unless
you're an idiot like I am yeah here here
why I mean the engine evaluation is just
not right I mean sorry it's just all
right this position is slightly better
for white because this is weak and
there's no compensation for that
absolutely not I mean he might be if he
is precise then black might get to an
equality but he has to be precise for
that and I played it badly so blaming I
think before I looked like a very
reasonable game I think yeah a night
before as the usual rules as far as I
know but you could see eight meters this
is not bad and I think in particular we
Nate was an interesting choice my move
Bishop g5 is probably not the best but I
didn't really see anything good my main
issue was that young Bishop takes I mean
I saw that I can go here and that taking
here on a - it's not really a point but
I didn't see what I have if you just
play c5 but it might be better than the
game I mean this is this is just still
probably just an equal position it's
very difficult to to be worse here Queen
should be for net is a good move
that makes no sense because he many can
take but this now looks rather
uncomfortable
because the pawns are weak for no
compensation
but what did what he played well is this
here now rupee eight and here again I
mean the engine might say zero but this
is just easier for white to play the
problem was simply that I didn't react
well to age five which which is a good
move
you
I was a bit scared about h4 so I went
queen bee form and then I'm stuck there
the vocal in situ which is uncovered
this is maybe the reason actually why
the engine believes this position is
equal and not better for ride that the
counter play on the kingside is so
substantial that I have no way to go to
some sort of better ending it's it's
very much possible Queen before seems
wrong
but if I have to play this for example
which looks a bit odd anyway then I'm
happy to consider this is equal but what
is best here oxy to look to see one
immediately
I asked this H five idea I didn't I
didn't really appreciate that and that
should that is okay then if he can
generate this counterplay it's funny yet
it 97 is a draw
why I said it wrong
ah because I am covering this I'm just
covering this then I'm even better yeah
I mean why even winning
like g6 and then winning huh interesting
that means that 95 wasn't even best year
age 4 was best
because if I check then before
Wow
well so here 97 was sailing really and
now probably I know I don't think that
there are certainly in in accurate moves
we didn't have time but he didn't
blunder it away we are here now Cana -
three chickens unavoidable ok with Queen
h4 isn't helping either
it's not like I'm holding this Feeney
that looked like a very well played game
a black actually I mean this is ok Queen
d4 he didn't save it this is not the
most obvious move and I didn't I didn't
think about it at all
yeah other than that that he played
excellently I think
you
what is this you met here is probably
enough counterplay I mean the bishop is
under I mean this is covered ff2 is
covered burned by the night but black
has this basic activity and inch 5 is a
huge point drilling that gives him a
love plane ok guys thanks for watching